september 15th and that means it is
roberto clemente day around major league
baseball a very special day throughout
the game and in particular a very
special day for jose trevino
and when you look back at the life and
the legacy
that roberto clemente left behind it is
definitely worth honoring humanitarian
efforts
are well documented and definitely
worthy of being celebrated
on the mound tonight for the rangers
o2 pitch
and this one bounced to third base
brock holt is there in his throw to
first just in time
to get diaz so two out of nobody on for
jordan alvarez a designated hitter 1-1
and this one hit hard out to right field
but right there for it is garcia and
it's a one two three first inning for
kohei arihara just nine pitches needed
bottom of the first jose or kitty on the
mound for your houston astros
that's outside ball four so
tavares with his good speed now is on to
start things in his first inning and
here's willie calhoun playing for the
first time in a big league game since
june the 26th
swing and a miss got him with the
change-up her kitty after a five-pitch
walk comes back with a three-pitch
strikeout but leone is seven for seven
and stolen base attempts this year there
goes tavares the pitch is high thrown
out of second is wildly into center
field and tavares hops up he'll head to
third base
no stolen base eighth of the year for
leote and he advances on the throwing
error
by maldonado and the rangers have a man
90 feet away
they're going back up there swinging a
miss for a strikeout the astros needed a
strikeout there with a runner on third
and the infield back with one out and
our kitty gets up so two out tavares
still at third and now it's nathaniel
lowe's turn
that ball hit well the other way going
back chaz mccormick makes a jumping
catch right on the warning track nice
play by mccormick to save her kitty and
the astro the run here in the first
here's kyle tucker tucker hits the ball
on the ground backhanded by solac off
balance throw tucker safe
kyle tucker getting down the line just
ahead of the throw
of nick solak he's the astros first base
runner so one on and one out and here is
jake myers the center fielder the 2-1
myers drives this one toward right
center field racing back as garcia still
going back looking up see you later
jake myers gets the astros on the board
with a two run homer two to nothing
sweet swing by jake showing power to the
opposite field four seam fastball middle
away a little elevated powers through it
shooting it out to right center field to
get the astros on the board early marwin
getting the start at third base today
with bregman getting the day off
marwin drives one deep to right field
back to back jacks the astros did not
have an extra base hit last night but
tonight they're often racing with
back-to-back home runs from jake myers
and marwan gonzalez that's only his
second home run as a left-handed hitter
his fourth home run of the year he's had
two with the astros peters right-handed
hitting left fielder batting 202 here's
the one-two
that's a bouncing ball left side
backhanded in the hole by diaz the
shortstop throws to first just in time
to get peters by about a step nice play
by letting me diaz filling in for correa
and there's one out well brock back in
action he was activated yesterday he's
missed few weeks battling covet oh this
ball hit well deep out to right field
tucker back to the wall and he goes down
hard
hulk will round second
he'll head to third and he's in with a
triple
tucker up and apparently okay
but that was a nasty noise he made going
face first into that thing good effort
either way just misses it off the glove
there you see the face first into the
wall that typically that could have been
a double but allows brockhole to get to
third here's hernandez miss hernandez
bounces one to short that scores hold
diaz up with its sidearms to first rbi
ground out hernandez is retired and the
houston lead is cut to two it's now
three to one here's the first pitch to
julie
and it's a shot and it's a single into
center field just over the leap of the
second baseman solac he was shaded
towards second base
and he leaped and he just came up short
and now the batter will be kyle tucker
he had an infield single his last time
up that ball slice the other way will it
stay fair yeah it's down for a hit and
towards the corner yuli heading to third
he'll put the brakes on there kyle
tucker an opposite field double in the
astros with second and third nobody out
and he hit marvin gonzalez as he goes
down but that's going to load the bases
and here's mccormick
line drive base hit left field one run
will score tucker being waved around
here comes the throw home tucker safe
two rbi single by chaz mccormick astros
lead five to one and that'll bring up dj
peters and it looks like hercules
getting on a little roll now
swinging a miss got him with the change
up righty on righty change piece to pick
up strikeout number three of the night a
one two three fourth for her kitty all
right altuve at second diaz at first
nobody out here's jordan alvarez
ball rocketed into right field that'll
score a run altuve will cross the plate
i let miss diaz heads to third yard on
with a
rbi double astros lead six to one that
ball was laced to right 111.5
off the bat and it was the same pitch
jordan went out there and got it smoked
there katie right now at 55 pitches
working in the fifth with one out here's
a 2-2
swing and a miss got him on a change up
and that's four strikeouts for katie two
out now it's brock holt's turn he has
the only hit for the rangers tripled in
the third oh two that's a ground ball
right side to his left is yuli he's got
it takes the first himself and it's
another one two three inning for jose or
keady he has set down the last nine in a
row and 15 of the last 16. so one out
and nobody on for tavares one two swing
get a miss
through the curve ball and tavares is
down on strikes five punch outs for jose
or katie tonight adolesce garcia the
batter 0 for two
there you go probably the last batter
that jose or keati faces tonight six
innings of two hit one run baseball a
great outing by erkidi who leaves
leading 6-1 astros with a 6-1 lead as we
start the 8th inning kyle tucker stands
in the 1-1
and tucker hits this in the air pretty
well the right center field going back
garcia at the wall looking up see you
later
into the rangers bullpen for kyle tucker
and the astros lead it 7-1 on tucker's
26 of the year boy tucker stays hot he
gets the ball in the air it's always got
a chance got a different sound when he
gets it on the barrel he's been doing
this since the beginning of may he's
terrorizing the league astros with a 7-1
lead over the rangers josh james on the
pitch the bottom of the ninth
3-1 pitch and this one lined out to left
field that's a base hit calhoun's second
of the night it'll go for extra bases
he's into second and will tiptoe in with
a lead off double have calhoun at third
with one out and a 1-0 count to
nathaniel lowe and 1-0
and it's pulled right side of the
infield it'll get the run home but low
retired by guriel and it is seven to two
astros rangers are down to their final
out
swang and a miss james strikes out dj
peters to end this one
astros win 7-2 kyle tucker a big night
three hits in a home run
and plummer one step closer to a fourth
a.l west title in the last five years
you